to present the best foreign language
film as a man who in 1976 wrote and
starred in a little movie called rocky
that went on to win Best Picture and
introduced the word yo to every language
except Hebrew where they read from right
to left which is why in Israel they say
Oh Adrian stop the hitting stop hitting
him I'll go to distance ladies and
gentlemen a great star mr. Sylvester
Stallone
movies are not holy theater their
classroom they teach us geography and
history exposes to art to music shows
the nature of man nature in the wild
which is too often the nature of man
every country makes films and we will
make them learn a great deal from each
other's work no matter what language
they speak or where they're made the
pure joy of movies is a universal
experience this year the native product
of five countries were nominated for the
Best Foreign Language Film they are from
Iceland children of nature friedrich
thor Fredrickson from czechoslovakia the
elementary school yon spheric from italy
Mediterraneo Gabrielle semi tortoise
from Sweden the ice
Sven Nykvist from Hong Kong raised the
red lantern Chung Gmail in the winner is
and the Oscar goes to Italy for
Mediterraneo accepting award the film
director Gabrielle Observatory
so mm I'm sorry I don't speak English
and thank you for this great toner
thank you for my producer Jenny
Minervini and paint Victoria cheeky
Gauri thanks for holding people who make
the movie and an invitation please make
no Duke heads like the soldier of
mediterraneo please stop the wars life
is better thank you thank you very much
from a hands of Darryl and Spike Lee and
Liza Minnelli